we are going to take I think we have
time for one more call at 6 1 7 830 4750
let's go to our caller from the 262 area
code caller what is your name where are
you calling from your the last caller
today so I hope it's really good alright
my name is David and I'm calling from
Wisconsin okay why are you curious on
your on your thoughts if the status quo
does not change with our current
projection of where we're headed with
energy management and the environment
management with the changes that we're
seeing with like the Trump
administration do you think that it's
possible that this society maybe the
like the last society that we see here
on earth so you're saying like because
of not not like catastrophic do not not
saying like it's the end of the world my
god but like almost a la walking dead
esque we're going to have a breakdown of
civilization at some point within maybe
the next hundred hundred fifty years do
you think that's a potential possibility
I think that we can see pretty
significant strife during the next
hundred and fifty years especially when
we're in such an accelerating curve of
both increased technological development
destruction of jobs as we know them due
to technology and increased inequality I
think that anybody who can tell you for
sure that there won't be a major
societal breakdown in the next hundred
and fifty years they're sort of speaking
nonsense because i think it's it's
reasonable enough to me pat to think
that 150 years is a long time at this
point think about how much change
there's been in the last fifty years
compared to the last hundred compared to
the last 150 and think about that curve
of change accelerating over the next 50
100 150 years whether it will be Trump
that is the catalyst that causes it i'm
certainly not ready to say that
particularly because we don't know how
long is going to last but i think we
could see significant strife and
cataclysm in
human society on ours in the next
hundred and fifty years well it seems
that the color was suggesting that maybe
because of our energy policy and the
environmental policy that we're adopting
is that where we're getting out here yes
okay yeah I mean some people don't even
admit that climate change is being
caused by human beings so if you can't
convince them of that how can you
convince them that in the next hundred
and two hundred years or so will face a
catastrophe of some sort what I
definitely think David is that if energy
consumption does start to have an acute
impact to the degree that even access to
electricity starts to become more scarce
I have no doubt that that is going to
escalate violence over you know we've
talked about the possibility of water
wars we may well see electricity wars if
if that starts to happen so yeah I think
that we're not going in a good direction
right now to put it succinctly yeah fair
enough I would agree all right
appreciate the call thank you so much
that is going to do it for this week we
will do audience questions next thanks
so much to everybody who called in